marine Calmet comment vous
définiriez-vous avocate militante
guerrière gardienne de la nature un peu
tout ça en vérité euh moi j'ai adopté le
terme de gardien parce que il renvoie à
la fois une certaine forme de poésie et
en même temps un rôle très sérieux c'est
celui vraiment de se dépasser soi-même
en tant qu'humain et endosser cette
responsabilité de représenter plus que
les simples humains aussi la nature les
écosystèmes dans lesquels nous vivons et
dont nous avons la responsab pleine et
entière alors vous êtes jeune diplômé
mais vous comptez déjà quelques beaux
combats le projet minier la montagne
d'or soutenu en son temps Guyane par
manmanuel Macron le père de flamandville
aussi qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à vous
intéresser à ces sujets là leur
dimension elles sont le symbole d'une
société qui va mal qui surexploite la
nature qui transforme les paysages qui
détruit le monde dans lequel on est
pourtant implanté et donc du coup pour
moi c'est cette dimension pharaonique
qui était le symbole d'une société
malade d'une société qui vit dans
l'outrance et dans l'irrespect du vivant
dans le cas de Flamanville un arrêté du
ministère de l'écologie a permis à la
centrale de continuer à fonctionner
alors même qu'elle avait été jugée non
conforme en raison de de de de de de
failles de sécuritaire des aberrations
comme celle-ci vous y êtes souvent
confronté oui parce que typiquement le
droit nucléaire c'est comme un droit
exorbitant c'est un droit qui est
tellement lié aux intérêts je dirais
politiques qu'en fait euh on le
transforme on le façonne parfois en
délaissant euh des choses aussi simples
que la sécurité la plus essentielle de
nos populations ou des considérations
écologiques et donc sous prétexte de
sauver les intérêts économiques et bien
on va faciliter des dérogation qui sont
irresponsables comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui une société par exemple
une entreprise a plus de droits que la
nature ça devrait être le contraire à
priori on devrait donner des droits à la
nature et pas à ceux euh qui l'abîme
justement ou la nature n'a aucun droit
dans notre société ce qui n'est pas vrai
de toutes les sociétés évidemment il y a
énormément de
sociétés historiquement qui protégeaent
en priorité les communs et qui justement
mettaiit de côté ou je dirais canalyser
les intérêts ou les les les pulsions
individuelles exactement or dans notre
société mais c'est un mouvement
historique assez récent en fait au
regard de l'humanité et même du monde
occidental là où traditionnellement on
protéger les communs et bien
progressivement avec la création
justement même de la personne morale qui
est un ovni juridique il a encore
quelques centaines d'années la personne
morale devient de plus en plus puissante
au fur et à mesure aussi que son capital
augmente quand vous avez des sociétés
qui pèsent aujourd'hui aussi lourds que
des États mais forcément ça déséquilibre
ce rapport de force et ces personnes-là
qui représentent euh un intérêt privé et
bien se retrouve à chuchoter à l'oreille
de ceux qui font la loi et c'est comme
ça de de fil en aiguille que une
personne morale peut avoir le respect de
sa de son image le respect de sa
propriété au détriment de tous les
autres et on pense à de nombreux procès
environnementaux qui l'ont illustré et
notamment par exemple Texaco chevron en
Équateur où justement des pollutions
monumentales ont conduit à énormément de
morts de malades une forêt décimée sur
de très nombreuses décennies et une
multinationale qui se cache derrière le
droit pour justement sentir alors où où
en est-on justement de de ce procès
Texaco chevron en Équateur parce que
l'équateur a inscrit les droits de sa
terre la Terre mère dans sa constitution
oui et d'ailleurs ça avait mené à une
condamnation en Équateur mais euh Texa
cochevron a réussi à à casser ce
jugement en se cachant derrière le droit
international et reste aujourd'hui
parfaitement impuni et donc et ça c'est
le cas dans de très nombreux endroits
dans le monde je veux dire l'équateur
justement ce qui est fondamental à
retenir de l'histoire c'est que
justement le peuple d'Équateur
traumatisé par cette histoire
extrêmement lourde a eu et a saisi
l'occasion de réviser sa constitution et
intégrer en 2008 les droits de la Terre
mère dans l'article 71 de sa
constitution aussi pour dire plus jamais
ça l'équateur a révisé sa constitution
mais ça n'a aucun impact juridique
concret sur sur Texaco etchevant sur
cette affaire en particul parce que le
droit international lui est régi par
toute un tas de considération libérales
et puis surtout parce que du coup tchaco
chevon se cache notamment derrière les
tribunaux d'arbitrage c'est cette
justice privée qui justement lui permet
d'échapper à la justice nationale celle
de l'équateur alors que d'autres
sociétés minières qui souhaitent
s'implanter en Équateur et bien se
retrouvent confronté à cette justice et
récemment on a de très belles victoires
l'année dernière par exemple dans la
forêt de los sedros le juge a annulé les
permis miniers délivrés aux entreprises
euh à la demande des citoyens à la
demande des collectivités et euh à
donner l'opportunité à l'état justement
d'Équateur de réécrire un plan de
gestion intégrant particulièrement la
question de la protection des droits de
la nature comme un un un présupposé à la
bonne gestion de ce territoire alors on
va parler bien évidemment des failles
juridiques et du droit international et
du droit français en matière
d'environnement mais je voudais revenir
à vous euh vous avez fréquenté marine
Calmet les grands cabinets d'avocat mais
également euh les chemins de traverse
notamment ceux de Notre-Dame des Landes
qu'êtes-vous allé chercher à Notre-Dame
des Landes et qu'en avez-vous
retiré moi je me suis toujours
intéressée disons à à ces luttes de
terrain parce que elle nous montre aussi
la diversité des moyens d'action c'est
cette richesse qu'on retrouve dans les
territoires et qui ne fait pas que
contester mais qui protège aussi un
certain idéal un idéal dans lequel
justement les êtres humains vivent en
harmonie avec leur terre ne sont pas
dans cette relation de prédation de
violation des droits de la nature mais
au contraire se voi comme des gardiens
et des gardiennes de leur territoire et
disent ce projet est fondamentalement
incompatible avec le futur que je
souhaite laisser à mes enfants et ça
c'est je pense que c'était aussi les
luttes de notre- Dame des Landes tous
ces grands projets en fait illustrent
fondamentalement la rupture avec le
monde de ceux qui se projettent comme
étant les propriétaires de cette planète
ceux qui peuvent exploiter le à outrance
la terre et tout les éléments de la
nature et les autres qui se voient comme
partie prenante comme memre inséparable
de cette communauté des vivants et quand
on est juriste et surtout quand on
arrive comme ça dans un territoire et
qu'on a la liberté et la la possibilité
d'observer ben c'est d'une richesse
énorme parce qu'on se rend compte à quel
point oui sur notre planète il y a des
mondes très différents qui existent et
après il s'agit de choisir à quel monde
on souhaite appartenir est ce qu'on
souhaite défendre moi j'ai fait mon
choix alors marine votre combat ne date
pas d'hier le juriste américain
Christopher Stone défondait déjà dans
les années 70 des seyas millénaires
contre Walt Disney la firme de Micky
s'apprêtaé à les raser pour construire
une station de ski et un parc
d'attraction en quoi est-ce crucial
d'accorder des droits à la nature en
fait ce qui est fondamental dans la
pensée de Christopher Stone c'est qu'il
nous permet de dézoomer en fait au
niveau historique il nous rappelle dans
dans son ouvrage Les arbres doivent-ils
pouvoir plaider à quel point l'évolution
de la personnalité juridique et F
fondamentalement lié à la culture à
l'instant et à l'éthique qui se trouve
dans cet instant il dzome historiquement
nous rappelant que pendant une très
large partie de l'histoire de l'humanité
les esclaves noirs étaient privés de la
personnalité juridique ils étaient la
propriété de leur maîtrre il nous permet
aussi de revenir à l'histoire des femmes
les femmes considérées comme des
incapables classé comme des enfants des
fous même dans le régime français les
femmes étaient sous la tutelle de leur
mari ou de leur père et de cette
manière-là Christophe firstone essaie de
réveiller notre mental en nous disant
ici donner des droits à la nature
reconnaître ces droits fondamentaux du
vivant était tout simplement le chemin
éthique le plus normal à suivre parce
que et il l'illustre la personnalité et
les droits fondamentaux accordés à
autrui est une histoire finalement
d'accroissement euh concentrique
progressivement la société s'élargit et
considère les intérêts d'autrui de
manière de plus en plus large et
aujourd'hui Christopher Stone du coup
nous amène à réfléchir est-ce que
élargir la focale n'est pas absolument
nécessaire dans la situation de crise
environnementale dans laquelle d'urgence
d'effondrement climatique oui et lui se
place dans les années 70 et donc ce qui
était connu déjà il parle du
réchauffement climatique dans son livre
il parle de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité et aujourd'hui si le
mouvement des droits de la nature est en
train de prendre très largement dans le
monde justement d'Amérique du sud
jusqu'aux États-Unis en passant par
l'Ouganda et l'Inde c'est parce que
justement on ressent profondément cet
appel aussi à la fois éthique politique
juridique de s'aligner avec le fait tout
simplement que les nonhains ont
forcément des droits et qu'il s'agit pas
de leur donner des droits ou de leur
conférer mais tout simplement de les
énoncer car ils ont toujours été là
comme les droits fondamentaux humains
ont toujours été là du fait de notre
naissance et de notre qualité en
essayant de prendre un peu de recul et
encore une fois c'est ce deszom
historique qui est absolument nécessaire
j'en avais parlé dans mon livre je pense
qu'il y a trois ces trois étapes ces
trois fameuses étapes pour arriver à ce
qu'une idée s'installe pleinement dans
la société au début quand on parlait des
droits de la nature les gens riaient de
nous ils se moquaient ouvertement de
l'idée de donner des droits à des
fleuves à des forêts c'était ridicule
l'étape numéro 2 je dirais c'est celle
de devenir un danger et là on ne rigole
plus là d'un coup c'est sérieux on est
face à à des personnes qui qui
sérieusement remettent en question
l'ordre établi et là forcément on a un
mouvement de recul ça devient une
confrontation entre deux ordres du monde
justement et je me suis dit bon il faut
voir plus loin ça veut dire que la
troisème étape et celle qu'on souhaite
atteindre elle est finalement devant
nous peut-être déjà atteignable c'est
celle où finalement l'idée devient
banale et il faut en passer par cette
deuxème étape du rapport de force pour
qu'ensuite l'idée devienne parfaitement
acceptée dans notre société et que
demain finalement les droits de la
nature cette défense du vivant soit
absolument mainstream et j'en suis
profondément convaincu rien qu'avoir
l'éducation aujourd'hui de nos enfants
qui changent leur
mentalité même dans dans les médias ou
dans l'opinion publique l'idée que nous
soyons pleinement et responsable de la
nature elle est en train de faire un un
chemin très rapide et incroyablement
fulgurant et donc ce que nous
aujourd'hui nous avons du mal à défendre
dans des circonstances qui sont
difficiles je pense que nos enfants nous
remercieront d'avoir tenu bon bien sûr
alors effectivement plus le climat se
détraque plus les citoyens se rebiffent
plus les procès se multiplient on en
compte une centaine de par le monde le
droit peut-il réussir là où le politique
a échoué en fait les deux ne peuvent pas
euh être déliés hm hm HH le la politique
en fait est l'affaire de tous en théorie
le mouvement des droits de la nature
prend justement dans des territoires où
un un droit souhaite être imposé depuis
le haut ou voir depuis l'extérieur c'est
justement le cas lorsque des
multinationales arrivent et imposent
leurs droits et le mouvement des droits
de la nature s'il prend comme ça par
petite oasis et bien c'est justement
parce que il crée un espace dans lequel
les cito yens disent nous n'acceptons
plus ce droit néocolonial nous
n'acceptons plus ce droit qui ravage
impunément le vivant et nous voulons
notre propre droit parce que nous ne
voulons pas être dans l'illégalité nous
ne voulons pas être considérés comme des
des terroristes nous avons nos propres
lois et ces lois elles sont
respectueuses du vivant elles sont
respectueuses de notre identité de nos
traditions de notre histoire c'est comme
ça justement qu'en Ouganda on a
l'adoption d'une loi sur les sites
sacrés c'est comme ça qu'en Inde
justement des citoyens se battent pour
les droits du camp ange de l'Himalaya et
bien ces poches de résistance disent
nous avions un droit avant que ce droit
libéral arrive nous avions notre droit
et celui-ci reconnaissait pleinement que
nous sommes interdépendants de la nature
et que nous sommes responsables d'elle
et donc pour ne pas sombrer justement
dans l'illégalité on oppose ce droit de
la nature comme étant un droit juste et
un droit qui garantit sur le long terme
les fondamental alors justement les
droits accordés à la nature vos
adversaires craignent les droits
opposables c'est une concurrence entre
les droits de la nature qui primerait
sur les droits humains et cette crainte
va jusquà l'Élysée puisque Emmanuel
Macron a été le premier à craindre que
les droits de la nature viennent
contrecarrer les droits humains oui et
là c'est c'est là qu'il y a une très
grande
confusion en fait aujourd'hui et c'est
jusqu'aux plus grandes instances comme
Antonio gouterz l'ONU et cetera tout le
monde aujourd'hui convient qu'il n'y
aura pas de protection des droits
humains sans protection de la nature
aujourd'hui les plus grandes instances
internationales ont acté défini faux
procès absument en fait non c'est pas un
faux procès c'est délibérer c'est-à-dire
que derrière il y a l'idée de faire
passer le message que protéger la nature
c'est forcément incompatible avec les
intérêts humains et ça c'est une opinion
politique c'est une visée aussi parément
libérale de se dire néolibéral
néolibéral ce sont finalement nos
libertés ou la nature et ça c'est c'est
une vision politique on essaie de
distiller dans l'opinion tout comme
d'autres concepts comme l'écologie
punitive servent justement à nourrir
cette pensée libérale et donc euh là
aujourd'hui le mouvement des droits de
la nature justement a cette idée que il
faut déconstruire cet imaginaire et
faire en sorte que nous intégrions
pleinement que nos droits fondamentaux
sont interdépendants des droits de la
nature la nature et l'homme font partie
du même système et et donc c'est
profondément la même chose en fait de
défendre les droits de la nature et les
droits humains l'ancienne ministre
Corine le page estime néanmoins que
cette question de droit en soulève
d'autres d'ordre démocratique notamment
comment représenter ces écosystèmes
dit-elle et entités devant un tribunal
sans les trahir ni les instrumentaliser
elle pose la question je vous la pose en
fait aujourd'hui et beaucoup S plignne
c'est ça passera notamment par une
reconsidération une revalorisation de la
pensée scientifique aujourd'hui la place
laissée à la science dans nos siété
malheureusement on le voit elle est
infime on a de multiples instances
scientifiques le Conseil national de
protection de la nature le Haut Conseil
pour le climat tous sonnent l'alarme en
disant nos politiques vont dans le
mauvais sens et parce qu'il s'agit
uniquement d'instan consultativ et bien
nous n'en tenons pas compte enfin quand
je dis nous je ne'y intègre pas
évidemment le gouvernement et les lois
promulgué n'en tiennent pas compte il y
a un infime pourcentage des lois qui
font l'objet d'un bilan carbone et on ne
connaît pas en fait l'impact écologique
des lois des programmes des
règlementations que nous adoptons or
justement il s'agit de redonner du poids
à cette connaissance scientifique pour
qu'on puisse prendre des décisions
éclairées de ce qui est bon pour la
nature et ce qui est pérenne sur le long
terme du coup voilà et une société qui
se base sur des lois qui sont
fondamentalement incompatibles avec le
vivant est une société qui ne peut pas
être pérenne sur le long terme en 2021
le fleuve de de tavignanou en Corse a
bénéficié d'une déclaration de droit de
la nature qu'est-ce que cela signifie
concrètement est-ce que cela pourrait
faire jurisprudence alors en fait il
s'agit d'un mouvement qui prend un peu
partout dans le monde on a une
Déclaration Universelle des Droits des
rivières qui a été écrit avec de
nombreux juristes scientifiques du Earth
Law Center ce modèle comme la
Déclaration universelle des droits de la
Terre Mère sert en fait à répliquer des
initiatives un peu partout dans les
territoires nous on travaille aussi sur
la déclaration pour les droits de de la
Sene sur la Garonne en haut de Savoie
sur le Chiran le nantbénin toutes ces
initiatives en fait prennent à partir de
Poch de citoyens justement qui
constatent dans leur territoire
l'implantation d'une nouvelle décharge
comme c'est le cas en Corse de retenu
colinaire en Savoie pour le ski et la
neige artificielle sur la Garonne de
pollution de de barrages ou de projets
polluants il y a il y a tout un tas de
citoyens en fait qui se saisissent de
cet outil des droits de la nature pour
faire monter ce sujet en disant voilà
voilà les droits que devrai avoir nos
fleuves nos forêts nos rivières et il
conteste comme je vous disais le système
actuel grâce à cette déclaration les
droits que devrait avoir la nature mais
concrètement aujourd'hui en France
est-ce qu'un citoyen peut engager des
poursuites contre des pollueur au nom
d'un écosystème dégradé ou menacé ou
saisir l'État pour s'opposer par exemple
à un projet qu'il considérerait
désastreux pour l'environnement est-ce
que c'est possible alors justement ça
c'est un grand problème c'est que en
tant que citoyen isolé vous êes sauf si
vous êtes laisé personnellement par un
préjudice écologique vous ne pouvez pas
agir ce que je trouve personnellement
anticonstitutionnel puisque notre charte
de l'environnement prévoit que chacun a
l'obligation d'agir pour défendre
l'environnement donc ça c'est à mon sens
quelque chose qui doit évoluer dans
d'autres pays comme en Équateur ou en
Inde on parle d'AC popularis c'est
l'action qui est ouverte à tous les
citoyens de défendre l'intérêt public ce
n'est pas le cas en France à mon sens ça
doit évoluer justement pour que chacun
puisse défendre juste les droits de la
nature oui pour que chacun puisse les
défendre l'écode par exemple n'a pas été
reconnu dans le droit français la
convention citoyenne l'a réclamé et le
gouvernement a totalement détricoter
cette loi pour en faire un délit de
pollution grosso modo pour poursuivre
l'état une entreprise il faut montrer
l'intentionnalité de nuire oui ce qui
est très dur à comprendre aujourd'hui
dans ce modèle juridique ce qui était un
vrai blocage c'était que l'État se
retrouvait finalement à être contredit
dans son action on autorise aujourd'hui
énormément d'activités qui sont
fondamentalement incompatible avec les
besoins du vivant et ce qui finalement
était une remise en question l'écoside
était une remise en question de ce
modèle et les entreprises disaient mais
comment se fait-il que demain on puisse
nous donner l'autorisation et ensuite
nous contraindre par le droit et bien
nous nous voyons la nécessité
aujourd'hui de euh donner la possibilité
d'agir pour ecoocide lorsque
malheureusement des considérations
économiques des considération euh
strictement financière ont justifié
certaines activités il faut donner la
possibilité au juges d'agir lorsque les
droits du vivant ne peuvent pas
justement être garantis sur le long
terme et donc là on avait un modèle
malheureusement euh de une proposition
l'coscide qui qui a fait peur qui a fait
peur et en même temps j'ai envie de dire
elle a ouvert un débat oui mais il faut
se projeter sur le long terme l'écoocide
écrit Dominique Bour n'est pas le crime
ultime mais le crime premier le crime
transcendantal celui qui réunerait les
conditions mêmes d'habilité de la Terre
ce crime aujourd'hui marine calm n'est
toujours pas reconnu oui les entreprises
ont-elles un devoir de vigilance oui
évidemment alors on l'applique très mal
puisqu'on voit à quel point le juge a du
mal à se saisir de cet outi devant les
tribunaux il y a plusieurs procès qui
sont en cours on n' pas encore de grande
jurisprudence pr par exemple ah oui bien
sûr mais mais d'ailleurs on connaît
parfaitement je veux dire par exemple
dans le domaine social lorsque vous ne
protégez pas vos salariés et bien un
chef d'entreprise peut parfaitement être
condamné pour avoir mis en danger estce
concrètement la criminalité
environnementale est en hausse plus 7 %
entre 2016 et 2021 mais il y a peu de
risque d'être contrôlé faute de
personnel suffisant formé et les
sanctions sont relativement faible
autement dit la réponse pénale n'est pas
du tout disuasive aujourd'hui en France
oui c'est pas nouveau malheureusement en
fait ça vient d'une culture assez
profonde d'ailleurs quand on est allé
rencontrer notre ministre de la Justice
celui-ci a dit face aux citoyens face à
moi-même il n'y a pas de crime contre
l'environnement en fait Éric duporetti
le G des sa oui oui parce qu'en fait
pour lui il n'y a que des délits
finalement contre la nature on ne peut
pas commettre de CRIM contre
l'environnement pourtant si pourtant si
et on le voit aujourd'hui il y a des
crimes majeurs commis contre la nature
chaque jour et donc en fait ça vient
profondément d'un d'un oubli d'un
impensé parce que nous sommes dominant
sur la nature et pour ça encore j'aime
utiliser un comparatif historique
j'avais une discussion avec ma
belle-mère l'autre jour qui s'est
beaucoup battu pour le droit des femmes
et elle me disait tu sais ce que tu
portes avec l'écoocide ça me fait penser
à nos débats nous pour la
criminalisation du viol parce qu'on
considère aussi trop souvent notre
société que violer est une femme est un
délit parce que les hommes finalement
dis dispose du corps des femmes et que
si ils prennent c'est bien que ces
femmes étaient disponibles elles se sont
trouvé soit au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment soit malhillé soit en de
mauvaise compagnie donc finalement c'est
la faute des femmes ce qui leur arrive
bah pour la nature c'est un peu pareil
on considère que prendre le corps de la
nature en disposer et bien c'est le
droit des hommes donc aujourd'hui votre
combat c'est de faire reconnaître le
crime d'cocide
oui c'est un changement culturel profond
parce que c'est tout simplement
reconnaître que notre relation à la
nature elle a malheureusement un côté
criminel lorsqu'on est incapable de voir
que ce qu'on cause et pour toute
personne qui est descendue par exemple
dans une mine comme je l'ai fait qui a
constaté la destruction massive des
entraille de la terre par les êtres
humains des machines qu'on a inventé
pour littéralement vider la terre de sa
substance et bien on se rend compte à
quel point la la domination et la
violence marque notre relation à la
terre
quand un industriel est condamné pour
avoir pollué une rivière par exemple qui
reçoit les dédommagements euh les
indemnités l'État qui subventionne par
exemple les énergies fossiles ou les
associations qui se battent bénévolement
et peineent à rembourser leurs frais
d'avocat où va cet argent ben souvent
oui alors les les les les condamnations
vont à l'état les associations
heureusement euh peuvent bénéficier dans
dans certains cas du remboursement de
certains frais mais en fait il faut voir
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
citoyens qui par leur implication par
leur temps mais aussi par leur argent
aident des associations qui font un
travail d'intérêt public et ça
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est très
compliqué je trouve euh dans notre
manière d'agir et qui a un frein
monumental c'est le financement des
associations qui sont vraiment et je le
pense pour avoir travaillé et travailler
tous les jours avec des associations qui
font un travail extraordinaire s'il n'y
avait pas les associations en France
pour protéger l'environnement la
situation aujourd'hui elle serait
gravissime j'ose même pas imaginer à
quoi ressemblerait la France si en
Guyane il y avait pas eu ces collectifs
justement qui tous les jours font ce
travail pour protéger la forêt pour
protéger la Terre et partout en France
tous ces collectifs qui alertent sur la
pollution de l'eau qui qui qui qui
alertent au quotidien sur la destruction
de nos forêts c'est impressionnant
marine Gal la France a été condamnée
trois fois pour une action climatique
sans que ces condamnations ne Chang le
cours des choses vers qui ou vers quoi
se tourner aujourd'hui il y a une
expression que j'utilise souvent c'est
c'est de dire que le juge c'est l'homme
du passé le juge ne peut pas
contraindre l'État à prendre des
décisions parce que on a la séparation
des pouvoirs qui fait que il revient au
pouvoir exécutif d'exécuter de mettre en
place des politiques le juge constate
constate des effractions et c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans le cas des carences
fatives en matière de de lutte contre
contre le réchauffement climatique le
juge constate l'inaction de l'État mais
en fait la solution justement elle est à
l'intérieur de chacun de nous on ne peut
pas attendre de du juge de faire ce
travail à la place des gouvernants mais
on ne peut pas non plus en tant que
citoyen attendre du gouvernant qu'il
fasse le travail si objectivement tous
les indices sont là pour nous dire ce
gouvernement ne va pas le faire parce
que aujourd'hui on annonce au lieu
justement d'investir massivement dans la
protection des droits de la on investit
des centaines de millions d'euros dans
développer des nouveaux carburants pour
faire voler des avions verts c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'en fait construire un
imaginaire ça demande aussi que chacun
d'entre nous s'y mette et aujourd'hui on
a besoin vraiment d'un mouvement citoyen
qui se mettent en place et qui Chang
profondément la société ça va pas venir
du haut ça va venir de chacun d'entre
nous et c'est pour ça qu'avec
l'association wild legal nous on essaie
vraiment d'accompagner tous les
territoires qui souhaitent utiliser les
droits de la nature parce qu'on on a
compris que ça viendrait pas justement
d'une grande loi d'une nouvelle
constitution pas maintenant c'est clair
vu le modèle politique actuel c'est trop
tôt par contre ce qu'on voit en
travaillant localement c'est qu'il y a
des gestionnaires de parc naturels des
citoyens dans leurs communes des élus
des des des des présidents des
directeurs de parc de Syndicat de
Gestion des eau qui eux font ce travail
au quotidien et qui constatent le droit
de l'environnement tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui ça suffira pas une nouveau
de nouvell gouvernance biomimétique il
nous faut un droit qui soit respectueux
des fonctionnalités du vivant et qui se
disent comment on fait ça et là on peut
accompagner ces transitions parce que
localement oui on a aussi des petits
pouvoirs on a aussi la possibilité de
planifier on a aussi la possibilité de
recréer des gouvernances différentes et
ça en fait ça demande juste beaucoup de
volonté du courage et de la créativité
on le fait au quotidien merci merci à
vous